so meta which is the new facebook as if
facebook wasn't horrible enough for the
last 20 years first off is anyone on
facebook anymore i mean i know we're on
facebook i suppose but i don't have
anything to do with it and i don't you
know you're getting on facebook
sometimes i'm sitting on a plane and
i'll see someone with an ipad like going
through their facebook feed and i
haven't seen it i haven't been on
facebook myself in so long it's so nuts
you look at people on their feet and
it's like picture of a baby terrorist
attack trump bush
you know like it's just like so insane
video game this that like it really
could all make you nuts well a lot of
people i guess still are on facebook but
facebook realizes that they're losing
some steam so they've decided to rename
the company meta and they're trying to
push us on to this meta universe if you
don't know what this meta universe is i
would recommend that you watch
ready player one or you could read the
book ready player one they want us all
basically wearing vr helmets and living
in this digital world and perhaps that
is why they are destroying the physical
world and by the way the elites and all
of the people pushing this stuff they
won't have their kids doing it and
they'll continue to live in the real
world and have their yachts and all of
those things but they'll want you to do
it because what a great way to control
the masses just lock them into something
give them pleasure all the time make
sure you can control their finances i
mean it's just so obvious what's
happening right now it's crazy and yes
we are in a dystopian future and it's
happening right now well
meta the company meta they're moving to
austin texas we've got some info here
from the daily wire facebook's parent
company meta has become the latest
california corporation to at least
partly moved to texas as it has signed a
massive lease called the largest ever in
downtown austin now i want to address
something quick
daily wire of course themselves left
california left los angeles to go to
nashville tennessee but now facebook
which you know it's been in silicon
valley forever and you know zuckerberg's
got billions living the good life in
reality and he's going to put you in
your little vr box uh they're moving to
texas now it's interesting because
austin is the blue
center of texas right texas is obviously
a red state although not as red as it
should be i mean ted cruz only beat beto
o'rourke the furry guy by like a point
and a half last time so texas isn't as
safe as it probably should be
although now there's some signs pointing
that it is getting a little stronger red
but putting that aside they're going to
go to austin and the issue here is that
they're going to bring in
probably thousands i don't know how many
employees they're going to bring in or
whether it's going to happen all at once
or what but they're going to probably
bring in thousands of people who have
all been infected by the woke virus like
how can you work at facebook at this
point with their diversity and inclusion
and all of the [ __ ] that we know they do
related to the algorithm and
misinformation and their fact checkers
and all of that stuff if you work there
you're basically voting the wrong way
you're controlling information you're
probably somewhat woke you're a new
neo-racist because you believe in
critical race theory and all that and of
course i don't mean every single
employee but in essence thousands of
those people
are now moving into austin and they will
make austin bluer and by the way austin
has a lot of homeless problems now and a
bunch a bunch of other stuff but then
potentially make texas bluer this is
this is dangerous stuff and if you think
that that isn't dangerous enough just
people moving there and then ruining
something that was good well here's a
little video
that walmart put up about what your
shopping experience will be like when
you're in the metaverse
great looks like you need a good wine
pairing take a look to your right
your age has already been pre-verified
through your profile so no need to wait
for an id check just place the item in
your cart whenever you're ready
looks like that's everything on your
list
are you ready to check out with walmart
pay
i'll have the tv brought out to your car
thanks for shopping at walmart have a
great day
i just want to be very very clear i
don't want anything to do with meta i
get this is the new thing that the
system that the machines are going to be
pushing on us and do you get it about
the control part it's like oh you can
just sit in your room and you can go to
the milk section and you can go to the
electronics section and buy this buy
that and then a drone is going to bring
it to your house and maybe the drone
will you know fire a rocket at your kids
who knows or maybe uh if you've been a
bad person and perhaps you voted the
wrong way or didn't get vaccinated
perhaps walmart pay is not gonna work
for you or you'll have to pay more for
certain things or as crazy as it sounds
could they maybe charge you more because
you're white i mean these things i know
it all sounds nuts but the
this all of this awful [ __ ] hasn't
come to its final conclusion yet it
hasn't
done exactly what it's supposed to do
yet a lot of people think we're moving
past it and in certain places we are but
the machine
watch watch the matrix man the machine
finds a way of being in front of you and
i don't want anything to do with that
i'm going to try to live in the real
world call me old school